now some disturbing video to show you a
group of angry protesters showing up
outside of Mitch McConnell's house in
Kentucky this weekend the Senate
Majority Leader was reportedly inside
recovering from a broken shoulder when
this happened yes that is what she said
and Texas congressman Joaquin Castro is
coming under fire today for posting the
names and employers of Trump donors in
San Antonio to social media the post
accusing the people of quote fueling a
campaign of hate the labels Hispanic
immigrants as invaders that seems like a
dangerous thing to do great I believe so
but this is what happens when rhetoric
is actually tied to actions there's an
old saying and conservative thinks a
liberal is wrong but a leftist thinks a
conservative is evil so once you expand
this target of demonization if you
aren't part of the resistance then you
are against the resistance and that
justifies any kind of this behavior the
Castro campaign I mean they are
basically normalizing daxing and
intimidation tactics and what will they
have blood on their hands there are
people that are going to do this to you
and to you to us at some point yeah
because we will be demonized by the way
look we know that every major done over
$200 their names are published in fact I
learned over the weekend all of Donald
Trump's major supporters in Louisiana
Donald Trump has raised over six hundred
and ninety thousand a hundred thousand
dollars compared to all of the Democrats
they've only raised less than four
hundred thousand and so I'm reading this
story and all of a sudden I read the
names of all of the Donald Trump
doughnuts now did I run the social media
and say hey X I don't I'm not going to
use your shipyard ahead while I'm not
coming to your grocery store no this is
a tactic that people are using in this
quote-unquote
hyper polar polarized environment to
sort of help
I think it's the wrong way to do it but
that's what's happens Jesse that the
Supreme Court has protected donations
and through the Citizens United case
basically saying that you can donate
anonymously so that you don't have to
end up like this people don't want to do
that if you it's your right to donate to
a campaign but it might be your right to
privacy as well if this is gonna happen
right
I guess we're for less transparency now
because it's safer oh no I mean looking
there Daxing contributors to the
President and then on the other hand
they're saying and by the way disarmed
right so they're inciting violence
against an individual and they say you
know what don't be able to protect
yourself when people show up outside
your home like they did to Mitch
McConnell imagine if maggot hat-wearing
supporters surrounded Nancy's palace in
San Francisco and chanted the things
they chanted every single senator and
Congressman would be confronted by a
media member and said you have to
condemn you have to condemn this will
you condemn it would be all over the
headlines would be all over the network
news cycle and this is being buried and
this is dangerous and I think it's gonna
lead to violence because at some point
someone's gonna come out with a weapons
when someone trespasses them in their
house what do you think about the
protest at McConnell's house Katie look
situations like that never tend to end
well people who have been doxed have
been killed as a result of the police
going to the wrong house
so there are serious violent
consequences for this Mitch McConnell
called the police I hope that all the
people who were chanting murder were
interviewed and asked if they have
intentions to investigated - for wanting
to assassinate the majority leader of
the Senate but these mob mentality shows
of force of people showing up at
people's private homes is nothing new
the left has been doing this for twenty
thirty years I think just now it's been
amped up as they've been justified in
doing it and people haven't condemned it
as Donna has done which is a good thing
but they think it's justified because if
it's a white supremacist in the way in
the in the house then of course they're
allowed to show up and call for their
assassination it can be scary Donna
right I mean oh my god let me just say
this III have protection as a result of
just you know giving my opinion and in
the public sphere you tell but you
a little different and you know it's not
easy to live in this way whether you're
in a mansion or Palace or even just just
walking around this is on existing
nightly behavior but let me just say
something about Pro I used to leave
protests in my youth and the one thing
nonviolent protests which is very
important and I counsel people how to do
it is to abide by the law stay on the
sidewalk not throw not use Boon Heong
bullhorns and all this we've seen
protests now from Hong Kong to San Juan
Puerto Rico where you know everyday
citizens are out there protesting
government action but we should do it in
a non-violent way because one of the
things that separate us from the other
civilized world we have loss to protect
people to protest but to go out in front
of a person spouse it's just
that places like Media Matters and there
was another guy I can't think of his
name it was Dan Pfeiffer I'm not these
are these are people in groups who are
saying that Fox News News communications
director for president oh yeah and these
are people that are saying Fox News is
actually an an engine of white supremacy
so what they're doing is they're
painting a target on us and I saw Joey
Jones on Twitter basically saying that
he's you know he's going to sit at his
houses and protect his family and he's
and he's gonna hope that these kinds of
deep this expanding target of
demonization doesn't end up sending
somebody crazy to his house but remember
journalists are always target and we
have to protect your analyst
Joey's out I mean but Joey's a guy at
home and Joey knows how to protect
himself
I think he's got more gun Joey Jones
indeed